le salon du livre de montréal attire
normalement à chaque année près de cent
mille personnes
mais distanciation physique oblige
l'édition 2020 sera virtuel donc oui à
une déception mais en même temps il ya
une occasion d'aller rejoindre d'autres
mondes d'autres publics us et qu'elle
est bien faite la vie oui cette édition
virtuelle proposera 450 activités dont
des animations des confidences
d'écrivain et des tables rondes
accessible via le site internet du salon
du livre au lieu des traditionnelles
séances de signatures deux cent trente
auteurs dont jean philippe baril guérard
feront des tête à tête virtuel de 5
minutes avec chaque personne qui
achètera un de ses livres mais ça va
être serré des cours de rencontre où on
en est loin
la colère de voir comment ça va se
passer de quelque chose de drôle parce
que c'est spécial on est quand même en
représentation salon du livre mais je
vais en représentation de mon propre
bureau
si je laisse les gens rentrent et là mon
intimité il s'agit d'une femme qui se
retire
depuis le début de la pandémie huit
salons du livre ont été annulés au
québec
ce passage au virtuel pour celui de
montréal à moins de deux mois de noël
est bien accueillie par des libraires
mais on sait très bien que les gens
prennent des notes demande des cadeaux
font des listes qui viennent en
librairie après coup pour faire leurs
achats mais c'est surtout la présence
médiatique du livre que génère le salon
qui a un impact positif sur toute la
chaîne
les sept éditions en ligne n'est pas la
solution magique oui on va regarder
comment ça va se passer cette année on
va souhaiter que ça allait bien mais je
vous le cacherai pas un ordre que les
salons du livre viennent pour l'ensemble
de l'industrie du livre jeunesse au
roman et l'essai aux livres
documentaires
on a besoin de ces vitrines des belles
vitrines pour l'auteur des romans royal
et manuel de la vie sauvage
le salon 2020 est un mal pour un bien
honnêtement dans les circonstances ça
reste cool je pense que parce qu'au
québec sur cellphone est tellement une
grande proximité
les auteurs et les lecteurs c'est le fun
de trouver une autre façon d'aller
chercher cette d'aller chercher ce
contact
ici louis philippe ouimet radio canada
montréal